Yes, it's the same source. Well, it seems that the
japanese men u ter has released
a video that evaluates my Japanese,
so today I'd like to see it and give my impressions
.
Uchar Sophie speak japanese Fessho remedios Ah, Ichi
Omi Carp who
do i Produced Spinkey Group
4 c 3 po asd Speaker
japanese and forth
japanese ppap to
do a form to dotk
sports Border Haze
japanese for some
japanese
parder are
see
her to
do
voodoo ifo soaper
5st same source office golden ratio should be unique ski
p to do in japanese
5 ed 4 ing good speaker
zed n sa d speak
japanese wow ah fan
house maker wow
created the most useful skills in Japan  Do you think it's a person's instillation
Rose is the
best Japanese
exception Week
sab Heart Fine this
takes ad Scanpiece Pro
Swipe ma 4 s Mountain industry hec
I would like to express my opinion or impression in the UK
.  Well, if it's me or the top, I
think it's safer to say which one is the top,
I think
that the user also said at the very end of the video,
but
rather the top of the navel is a foreigner  The
question, "Is there a boy accent?" Is
ridiculous
, and I think that the higher ranks are much higher than the Japanese people there
.
However,
when I hear that person speaks both Japanese and English, I immediately understand that this person is really smart,
so
I have already asked the question of which is better, the Japanese of the same source or the higher-ranked Japanese.  It's out-out
, but it's nothing compared to meeting
anymore. It's
close to the native language even before the weather is good.
There's no way I can win, so
I'd like to ask you to remove the upper ranks
for a while and talk about the same source of sound. Well, if
it's Matt or I,
which one is better?  Certainly, as
Yuta-san said, Matt is better in terms of pronunciation, such as expressing what
he wants to say naturally, without making efforts without making efforts to correct his opinion.
I think it's above, but I
think that many Japanese people say that
Matt is closer to the native because he lost to the top overall,
but I want to say anything here.
There's something about it
, maybe there's only one place I'm buying,
and what
's that is Jaws me